[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of rissa fury i'm kelsey cook and we are
in the zodiac studios at moon tower
comedy festival in austin and i cannot
wait to play to
these incredible guests today uh i have
on trevor wallace and jeremiah watkins
show the guns yeah yep
we got a 98 degree shirt yeah it's about
to get hot in here in two ways puns
everybody loves puns leave a comment if
you love puns please don't oh my god the
content king already helping the
algorithm asking for comments
like and subscribe yeah yeah
yeah oh my god and then i had to
unfollow my father anyways
we uh we're so happy to have you today
is there any sort of foosball experience
that you're coming into with this
trevor
uh no i played at a buffalo wild wings a
few times sure that's just on leisure
sure yeah tuesday afternoon yeah no
serious bets just like who's picking up
the next pbr that type of stuff no
serious uh no my neighbor had one but um
no we we never we we never really played
okay i used to hit up uh my youth group
every wednesday night whoa back in the
day and uh
that was back when spins were allowed i
know spins aren't allowed these days
yeah what's
next can't be having that trash
don't bring your spinner trash i won't
be my bring my my church spinner trash
to uh to this table
i know you play legit rules out here
apparently everybody in my hometown
would just put like wood on top of the
foosball table like we can eat on this
table or that or beer pong they'd put a
plexi glass like table on it like a two
in one yeah yeah dining room table also
foosball table ping pong air hockey the
all-in-ones i for sure had a
fisher-price version of that growing up
the best truly the best yeah it was more
of an air hockey person okay
so the quick risk yeah yeah yeah yeah i
just like how cool it gets i get sweaty
if you can already tell so the ac that
was only ac behind our house you're
sweating
that is a that's a fat kid's dream sport
is to have air conditioning while you're
playing
vegetable misters exactly right yep
halftime just sprawled out zamboni just
give me a second guys just give me a
second yeah so hopefully this has the
same effect with this is that artificial
grass yeah we'll see about that did you
bring this here i did this you really
did well we coordinated it but this is
this is a tornado this is legit what's
tornado is that a college it is
not a college that's not a college
mascot
i mean maybe somewhere i have a state
school education so please excuse
any of this they're
not teakwood
i thought so is there a reason you guys
are going to have you playing forward
and you
just we haven't just discussed that yet
you need to take some time as a team
great whispering i would like to try to
win this for us so i'm gonna try to
score wow
what does that mean for me that means
you gotta bone up on your goalie skills
if you if it's if i start going real
rough then we'll switch okay but i feel
like a lot of the goals come from the
back no these dudes i think it's all for
show you know it's like in the army they
put these people up front they're like
yeah just defend and these are the real
shooters right here i don't think either
of us are going to be scoring from back
there
no no i don't think either of us have
the skills that's some big confidence if
you're coming in if you think that he's
like dude the goalie scores all the
goals in this game yeah right that's how
i play that's right
and you
told me ahead of time that you're
competitive i'm super competitive can i
take off my watch my 79 dollar movement
watch wow that's tick-tock baby how do i
take this off the moon wristband because
this is all
sorry so you're not wearing yours that's
how i knew this is rigged test her for
peds
is that what it's called pd's i do that
personal enhancement media lights but
there we go
yeah those electrolytes cool well just
know if i lose is because moon tower is
cutting out my restriction in my right
arm
okay okay we're jumping in we're gonna
first round we play three rounds first
round we're just gonna play game to five
he's gonna get look at how serious
jeremiah is already oh yeah he got this
iron this morning it's a serious day
that is a fresh tea oh thank you fresh
jersey yep
that scissor bros what up i gotta
represent for stevie out here i'm sorry
if i fail you go watch uh trumpet
tuesdays yes because jeremiah did a
cameo with my dad that was so fun your
family is so nice
it made sense like if you came from bad
people i'd be like this doesn't add up
at all but they're like the sweetest
people yeah yeah it's a good time so uh
all right i'm gonna let you start with
the ball okay so this is a sign of
respect just respect thank you for
coming here today yeah and that's as
nice what can we not do real quick you
can't do no spinning yeah that's i'm
already no jarring so you can't be
playing d so aggressively that it do you
see how it shakes the ball when i do
that
yeah you can't hit the sides of the
table like that over and over okay you
can like hit it once so exactly how i
grew up playing i can't do any of those
oh yeah just a kid but i was
told you can do a couple of these yeah
you can do that because you're not going
more than 360 when you do that you just
can't go you can't go no full rotation
no forwards yep okay
all right you ready dude yeah i think
we're we should be good okay here we are
this team right
i'm so competitive that i know he's
joking but i'm furious right now oh
jerry i'm a little colorblind so i am
worried for the rest of your day oh
because this is i'm gonna take my shows
at the festival tonight if i lose
there's a lot riding if you lose oh i
just
i know
you're you're trying to get inside my
head before we even roll have you lost
before no never no and this is the 27th
episode
i was saying in life you know oh i for
sure lost in life cobain died when he
was 27. let's freaking 27 let's go it's
the 27 club here we go
today i'm ready that's how competitive i
am let's do this you ready oh my god
yeah
okay let's do it ready
see i don't like the tee up it's too
mathematic over here it's very
how the
what did i tell you gotta let me score
views
all right all right hey all right hey
we're just warming up huh we play we
played at 20 yeah
[Laughter]
okay it's a loose game to 50. yeah
absolutely 55. have you always like had
that like stain right here
don't are you trying to get up with me
what did what is did what are you trying
to distract you have like i'm not even
gonna look down this is happening and
it's like a mustard no it's like a
mustard but it's like a dijon it's like
a fancy mustard actually it looks like
she's worn those quite a few times and
then that's why if you want to change
real quick we will no this is somebody's
already tried to with me adam ray
you can thank him
oh that's freaking go
freaking go okay let's drink it go
what's up okay what's up okay oh we're
were we bluffing beforehand
oh i don't know how to play jeremiah
hustling take your wait everybody client
on set client set oh yeah hear that
oh my god the point has anybody scored
on you today uh yeah oh okay well never
mind but yeah let me just deflate that
balloon real quick are you ready okay
oh no no watch out
how
are you sure you don't want to be goalie
let me let me let me try to write this
out let daddy make some moves up front
yeah daddy needs to bring him a ref if i
could stand on the couch that'd be great
all right here we go this is so
articulative
here we go
okay
she's a snake she's a snake she's snake
it up see it up do what you did
if you can't touch it you can just move
it with your finger
that's how official is that yeah you can
just do that oh jesus oh no no i don't
like this oh no no no no no she's about
to cast a spell on you dude watch out
when guardians oh yeah okay oh okay
no no no no no no come on come on come
on
see it's the build up
how okay see what i don't get is the
ball is here but then it's on the side
and then somehow
i can't even explain it
it's like watching somebody do a really
excited like why did i pay attention in
physics class why did i go to school in
general
all right too busy huffing axe cans this
is terrible
here we go i was more of a tag guy there
we go
off-brand yeah kirkland signature that
gave me a uh a massive rash one time and
i was like all right that was my last
the sickest rash ever had though
oh boy the back pass
oh jesus
how literally how
right so she's got four and we've got
one so if we're playing golf we're
winning okay
there we go oh
i don't know what my goal is just defend
pretty much
jeremiah where's your confidence right
now how are you feeling i still feel
like this is possible to
i mean
you know this is just game one and
trevor's proving himself as a goalie
somebody call instagram because it's
about to be up
i just liked watching you sit and never
say i know i was like where's this going
oh okay
oh
see the fatigue's kicking in
getting a little sloppy
oh
come on come on come on
maybe i can score from the back oh okay
oh you just
oh okay come on
oh come on
oh no no no
okay oh i did the thing i can't do that
i'm sorry somebody penalize me with the
spanking
all right there
so that's what we call and this that's
game one round that's game one how's the
game one yeah you want it do you want to
switch
you know give it a shot yeah uh yeah we
fought how many games we find yeah three
total okay so that was that was round
one it was wrong one so come over here
though because we're gonna we're gonna
choose some things that will make it
easier for you to beat me we're gonna
handicap me a little bit oh wow
okay
has anybody never taken the handicap
before
anybody never taken the handicap are you
jeremiah are you really gonna
try to forgo help
i mean i got that one point i mean
i mean it's anybody's game at this point
to be honest i mean you know we could've
you know started coming back has anybody
not taken the handicap no you would be
the first oh man
well i'm curious what it is then we can
and then we can and then we can say no
and then you can yeah sure so take a
ball all right you have a ball i know we
both both teams take a ball okay okay
what is your say number three okay so
you guys would start with two points
and mine is
four so i would have to play with a mask
over my eyes
yeah i why what we can discuss
the volume so mask and then we get two
points as well yeah
but here's the thing here's the thing i
don't like about it it's so humiliating
if we don't win this game
it's so like you know what i mean
let's just uh take her blindfolded but
we don't get the points
okay
boy that is a
bold move
like blindfolded blindfolded i'm gonna
have a mask over my eyes what kind of
mask n95
i think it through
i think it's just i don't think i'm
going to be completely blocked out but
it's obviously going to up my
vision quite a bit okay cool you take
that we also discussed before that you
guys could earn a bonus point
if you can name every member of 98. nick
lachey nick lachey nick lachey
nicholas shade
uh it's a uh
come on uh okay fine we'll we'll take
the
handicap you are wearing a shirt and you
don't know their names that is just yeah
uh
i don't i don't know at all it's too
vintaged out to name them
is the actual
brand new version
i mean it looks hard to see their face
honestly this looks like a lot of failed
sitcoms right here they didn't make it
that's true you know what i mean yeah i
know it's a boy band but it's also like
do they work at a fire department yeah
it's like thunder from down on you yeah
yeah yes
okay
let's if we win we get to be thunder
from down on it for a night so
you know it's that's really funny
because you guys don't
i'm not gonna say anything but
something's gonna happen later and your
predictions are are the thunder from
down under boys going to be here
you'll see strippers you'll see we'll
see what happens
okay so you guys don't want to start
with any points no
wow
this is so exciting yeah better yet you
start with the point
i'm just saying things i'm just bluffing
okay
oh i can't see anything through this oh
good why can't taylor say that she could
see
like nothing
literally nothing
it'd be a full blindfold all right cool
i like you know that's the rules you
know what i'm saying
sounds like you're backing out your own
challenge well who shows us now isn't it
good that we didn't take any points now
are are you going to feel good about
yourself beating a blind woman
yeah i will if you say it like that no
absolutely
okay
i would love to beat a blind woman yeah
if she's good at foosball if she's got a
i mean honestly kelsey you're so good
it's probably gonna be like a daredevil
thing where all your other senses are
heightened and you're gonna start
scoring even more right now so i don't
trust you okay
you're doing the thing uh what is this
is this a table is this is this a
foosball table excuse me guys
this is all an act he's done this before
i can see to be fair i can see like this
much out at the bottom i just want
people are you okay with that
i can see like this much
that one all right thank you okay okay
here you take it first okay
dude if we lose this
we're never going to be real friends in
real life
trevor and i are in a testing area where
we kind of know each other through the
comedy scene but we don't like hang out
like if it goes well we'll start up
because we start
but if it doesn't never again okay
oh it's down spin it's down go ahead
what is happening we have to make the
ball noise
oh come on oh man oh
oh no a reflexes thing
yep oh my goodness
is it
that's in the no man's land i'm gonna
touch it okay
all right it's back if it's between us
here it goes back to me
okay
up that's real
it goes back to you okay all right you
got it
i spin backwards
oh dude she almost scored
and it would have ripped my soul out of
my body i blocked it out of pure luck
this is some real mr miyagi stuff right
here
i'm honestly trevor i'm more stressed
playing her blindfolded then like you
know what i mean like because we have a
little bit of a cop out if
if she's just like good without the
blindfold um
okay she's got it she
oh sh
this is just the worst feeling
yeah hey kelsey what are you going
through right now let me
this is
oh like it's hurting my head it's
it's so disorienting to not
let's go let's go you can catch the new
trevor wallace jeremiah
oh
okay
all right dude we're doing exactly what
we were meant to do there we go all
right
i think she was giving us two points so
it wouldn't take 45 minutes probably
probably
oh you guys have three now huh
uh we didn't no we didn't take that one
but we couldn't take it none of that no
no no no no no no no no okay we got the
one we got the one
you guys ready yep
okay okay okay there it is okay there it
is there it is here we go hate this
punishment
honestly like i'm surprised that's even
in your your
whatever thing what are those called
challenge denny's ihop uh raffles uh
bingo raffle close there we go okay here
we go
okay
oh that's real close
oh
okay you got this you got this
no no no oh oh oh oh god bless you oh
man that was close
do you have a color preference when you
play every
yes wow
wow
i mean that was just pure
okay i felt good all right all right
okay here we go
ready
yes
[Applause]
oh
see she's got all these like this muscle
memory and reflexes of years it's the
tricks am i getting when i shoot does it
go down or does are you you stopping at
your phone
um
okay right now it's been on on our
offensive side for a little while but
you almost just scored
and then we just we just got from
downtown there we go trevor wallace from
the back of the field where you normally
score
yeah yeah trevor's comfort zone i'm
partying
no no we have three now yeah yep
okay
i'm stressing out guys good you know we
would have won if i hope you're sweating
as much as we are now all right very
much so
oh
okay so i can do a little techniques
oh what's that shimmy shake
oh okay
this is do people like tailgate for
stuff like this oh my god
do people tailgate yeah for this
what do you mean like do people get
up oh for like this big like you
know it's a big event you know a big big
one plan oh yeah so we're doing a
tournament on saturday shoot
and i feel i mean it's at 1 pm
rick yeah i was thinking about the
tournament though stay on task trevor
yeah yeah stay on our planet
no that was me no you have two i have
two
oddly close for somebody who's blind
yeah i know i
know
it'll be the trick shoes down
[Applause]
oh that's so close
okay
oh come on
how
yes i'm gonna go ahead and say that was
uh this is my fault i'll take that one
i'll be honest okay but just realize
that because we didn't take those two
points
we have to win this now because we would
have already won by oh oh yeah yeah
are you getting pissed
yeah there's so much rage inside me
right now
if this was like a disposable set i'd be
like
punching through a wall going up right
now yeah okay
okay
i know we'll really turn it on okay
there it is all right these mind games
mind you guys mind yours let's do this
come on the harder you try the worse you
do don't try okay
okay
come on buddy we got this
we got this
i feel like
because i'm blindfolded i also can't
talk for sure like yeah it's requiring
it's hard your motor skills are all
focused on just your hands and stuff
right now
oh man
i don't like that bouncing back and
forth thing
see you had to tie it up you got to tie
it up zoom in on this
yeah
zoom in on the fury this is the part of
the fury of wrist superior right now
it's not the wrist it's this angry face
right now
come on man it's one point we got this
come on
i'm a fourth quarter player okay all
right
oh okay
come on man
this and then went around
that's i mean look
i don't know what to tell you i i smoked
weed in high school i didn't play any
sports i'm not good at athletics this is
not
oh my god i own this loss i apologize on
behalf of the state of kansas uh i
apologize on my church youth group i
apologize on behalf of scissor bros uh
um i'm
blessed thank god
what a rush but we did actually win
mentally remember how you give us a
handicap
true
so it's it's best two out of three right
yeah technically but you already have
can we play the third game of course we
always play the third game
huh yeah yeah here's the thing winner
takes all
in the third game
is that real the first two doesn't
matter
if yeah technically if
but again nobody's ever i think this is
another trick but
yeah yeah mind games yeah okay all right
winner takes all third round best out of
three but only three matters how how how
are your uh
not great
i mean i can make a good kebab but i
feel like that's about as much as i
could do with okay hands do you want do
you want to switch here's the thing
though so in the third round we play two
ball
so we each start with a ball we go one
two three go
and you have to score both balls to get
one point if we each score balls to wash
oh wow okay
okay and
so you were talking about thunder down
under before yeah so your guys's
punishment if you lose
is that um you will each have 30 seconds
to give each other a lap dance
in the zebra chair what can we do if we
win absolutely okay cool that's more of
a victory lap for you i mean you know
more of a gift than sure whatever way
you want to look at it but
we just felt you guys are both so
physical mm-hmm and well really and yeah
right you're very i know you're physical
you can do it i don't know what you're
talking about
guys
let's do it six more games
we just felt like that would be a good a
good sight to see yeah yeah we'll crank
some tunes and okay do a little a little
lap dance what do you think
switch keep it
it's up to you
how comfortable how how are you feeling
about switching right now because i feel
like we got pretty close i don't feel
great about this whole game in general
so
uh do you want me to
i feel you want to run back up here
maybe all right
it's time to let the birdie fly okay get
out there okay
so what's your handicap for this one no
handicaps all right cool two ball
all right
yeah it should go great
i can just
i can just feel you right now
and i can feel you're genuinely upset
i'm
bubbling on the inside right now
okay are you ready
one two three go
oh oh oh hold on come on come
on come on let's freaking go
so is that two points that's one point
how's that what that has to be two
no points
right that's our handicap that's our
handicap we get two points wrong you get
what
but that was good that was good were you
was that on purpose no i don't know why
i never lose what i do like about
kelsey's character she is honest she at
least gives us props
yeah that was a good job
it's not gonna last very long but okay
okay ready one two three go
all right
good
see no comment all right next round okay
not available for guys
i know good job
good job good job okay ready one two
three go
there it is there we go
wash all right wash wash wash
how you feeling
it's your perspiration level i have
indigestion right now it's literally
it's hot it's caused me for my stomach
otc okay okay one two three go
see the thing is is they're too fast for
me
dude when she turns it on it's scary if
we could use like a croquet ball i think
it's a possession do you ever play uh do
you ever play pool kelsey
i do okay not as well as this but oh i'm
okay all right i'd love to play you in
pool i love
you are we gonna find a pool table later
yeah all right yep one two three go
no no no
oh wash wash wash great job
time for wash there it is
scored as a goalie all
right
one two three go
oh okay so it's up to you
thank you
i usually you know ask interview
questions as we're playing but it's just
been so tense it's been very that it
just doesn't even feel
appropriate right
what do you want to know about us i i
was gonna ask
i've been asking people today
what their
worst show
during the pandemic was like their worst
virtual show or outdoor show if there
was one you did it that
was really bad in particular oh boy
did you tour much during the pandemic
trevor uh i did but i was going to
places that didn't know there was a
pandemic like wisconsin right they were
just all about it
uh i did i did a uh uh it was a
louisiana restaurant wash
that's right yup to the louisiana
restaurant hush wash don't you
talk don't touch that scoreboard kelsey
one two three go
wash
come
on come on alive
okay one two three go
[Applause]
okay trevor you were saying that you did
uh oh i did a show like it looked like a
louisiana type of restaurant but it
didn't fit that at all there's people
smoking hook out front and i followed a
a dj who was just playing classic hits
and then everybody there i was yeah
everybody there was like above like 57
and then i tried to just do comedy and
it just did not it was a friend that
i've known forever hey man just started
this new room can you come do it i was
like sure i got you and i just i just
did not do well at all and it was like
25 minutes of just sadness yikes there's
one guy there who like saw a fly around
town who like loved me but he was the
whole time like yeah yeah yeah and
everyone else
have you ever just been bombing and
people eat shrimp cocktails it's a very
sad sight when you can hear them
oh i have uh one that before um it was
during the pandemic i was in new york uh
it was november of 2020
i did a show uh in an upscale new york
loft like kind of restaurant where
the audience
was allowed to not wear masks but all
the comedians had to wear masks to
perform stand up and i hated it oh my
gosh because the status level was like
perform for us you little fools and keep
your little mass on because you're
little animals who have coveted like i
hated it damn yeah that was no facial
expression oh no i was like i was like
hey guys good to see how i'm like
working with like everything i got like
all in this range just age your forehead
14 years in one show yeah exactly oh my
god yeah those both sound uh
terrible i mean the obligatory
zoom one zoom was that any of mine cause
then you're just like okay i can just go
to the kitchen afterwards you're just at
home yeah right i did a zoom college
show at one point for eight kids and
they all were muted when i got on and i
was like hey
you guys mind unmutant so it just feels
like you know
whatever one kid unmuted and so i
performed basically for one kid for an
hour was he was he good no
liked about 30 of the stuff it was
it was brutal could you tell when he was
opening other browsers to look at okay
you just see his eye shifting like hey
buddy over here
not there yeah i usually just went to
the chat for that like honestly guys
whatever joke is not as good as whatever
the hell you guys are talking in the
chat let's just talk about it exactly
yeah i say on stage now that the porn
star joke i do about jesse rogers being
my porn star look-alike i say that when
i was doing that on the zoom shows i
could just feel that halfway through the
joke everybody would just open a new
browser oh yeah google hangout because
yeah you have the ability the screens go
private and you're like where did
rodriguez just go do i hear all this
heavy panting yeah yeah you turn it you
didn't jump out why did they turn the
screen back on and they're sleeping
are you smoking a cigarette
now wear your mask huh yeah yeah
oh my god okay anyways uh so
back to back to this if you're ready yep
so score is two one right
three one three one
yep okay
one two three
[Applause]
the key is with this game i find if i
don't even try sometimes you just score
i think the key is with this one is with
the two balls is to be as
crazy as possible like with our shots
because
there's it splits your focus
like when she has when she has her focus
on the one ball she's going to get it
every single time yeah yeah so it's like
all in the first three seconds i think
was that a wall
ready one two three go
you always make that first one okay
all right one two three go
chip
there's a quick one
okay something needs to change here one
two three go
i'm just gonna stop it
you're gonna like the way you look there
it is okay there we go here we go come
on what does that mean if they both go
in is that good is that good for us i
think it's pretty good so good all right
if i had to guess it's three two right
now so just to
keep our ego and check where's your
worst jeremiah's by far the most
invested guest we've had on today in
terms of like
not giving up oh dude let's go let's
freaking go i'm ready one two three go
uh oh oh my god oh my goodness
no no no no no no
come on
oh that was looking promising
[Music]
[Laughter]
apologize for my behavior
it's four to two i got a little bit
light-headed when i did that one
i felt it
okay so
game point game point
not that everyone's counting those quads
ready a lot dance time oh shoot okay one
two three go
well
oh
oh good save oh god
get all this out of here
let's do it i know i really wanted to do
a pony by genuine but then for
legal reasons well you could do that and
then just like put in like other music
after
jeremiah
would you like me to hold your hand
honey
good game i'm just curious what camera
this is i think this is like the only
fan's camera of the year right there
that's been inside somebody for you oh
yeah yeah birth canals
this one particularly i think so can i
take it home i don't know where it came
from but
well okay i'm legit so disappointed in
myself right now oh i think you came in
with expectations that you shouldn't
have had
this is hurting me more than i was
hurting just a second ago by you saying
that
just let you know where my headspace is
did you did you think that we had a
little bit of hope ah no okay right off
the bat okay yeah well
congratulations thank you so much
we
bring in the zebra stripper chair
it's already stains on it what is this
colgate
how does it work okay
who would like to dance first let's get
out of the way we have music right yes
okay
just
just in silence
i'm just like sitting there i'm like
okay kelsey it's an interpretive dance
yeah this is a little based on your
emotions that you're experiencing yeah
um
[Music]
jeremiah you sit first at first trevor
can we get daddy's bar mitzvah huh
hold on let me get 30 seconds on the
clock
all right exactly when you start playing
music i'm starting the clock was it lap
dance yeah any dance
don't just start right in or it can be a
little seductive
different lights everybody give me some
some jergens 30 30 seconds to do
whatever feels right in your heart leave
besides that all right okay ready
hold on now
and we need to feel this face yeah feel
that
oops
can you check the time again oops
oh no
somebody's been a bad player
does somebody want to come off the bench
or does somebody just want to come
off no bench
oops
[Music]
what is
you looked like you
loved that
here's this we thank you
it's most money i've ever made
here we go
switch it switch it switch it
switch it and switch it
all right somebody give me a michelob
oh
these characters seem just like
the worst people in the strip club all
right
30 seconds
yeah
i hate my wife
oh jesus
what type of quinceanera is this
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my goodness couldn't have
found a longer song
30 seconds
holy
good sport all right you are a good guy
i'm a good sport great sport i'm a good
sport yeah no whisper somewhere else
i mean we did score that's all i really
like oh we got a microphone for you
jeremiah
i will not be going to disneyland today
i i shamed my family i shamed trevor
sorry buddy we almost we almost got a
podcast man we almost did we almost
started one for the park
congratulations kelsey thank you for
having us today on the show thank you so
much for doing it and being such great
sports you got it it was great i'm going
to go ice my forearms and cbd lotion now
can you guys tell people where they can
find you
crying
trevor wallace comedy.com for tour dates
trevor wallace instagram all the other
stuff trevor wallace at jeremiah stand
up on all social media
jeremiahwatchings.com for tour tickets
and i've got a great podcast called
scissor bros and jeremiah wonders that
you should check out on youtube
100 they're both such great follows
online please go follow them um my
instagram and tick tock are at
kelseygoodcomedy you can go to
kelseycook.com for tickets for tour
dates and please subscribe to the all
things comedy youtube channel so you can
see
more episodes like this because this was
magical
all right
we did it we did it really good yep
we'll see you guys next time bye
we good what's up
[Music]
you